fueled by strong winds and dry
conditions wildfires continue to rage
across California in Sonoma County north
of San Francisco winds of hurricane
strength help the Kincaid fire creep
closer to its population hub Santa Rosa
the blaze forced two hundred thousand
people to evacuate as daylight revealed
burned homes and structures the Wildfire
now covers more than a quarter of a
million square kilometres officials say
it's five percent contained
I'm cautious when I say this but
near-historic wind event at a scale and
scope the likes of which we haven't seen
in some time that precipitated today
with a new statewide emergency
declaration because 43 counties now are
impacted by red flag warnings and by
these severe weather conditions to the
west of Los Angeles the Getty brush fire
threatens hillside communities with a
number of homes already damaged the
city's mayor has warned some residents
they may only have 15 minutes to leave
officials say 500 firefighters are now
battling blazes that weather conditions
are expected to worsen so we have
firefighters from the ground and air
they had a very quick response to this
they've been able to try to anchor that
fire we're working on flanking it but
it's just moving in such a quick area to
prevent fire starting in other areas
electric companies have cut power to
more than two million homes and
businesses it's thought the Kinkaid fire
may have been started by a downed cable
according to the California Department
of Fire and forestry the state's
experienced its deadliest and most
destructive fires in the past two years
fire seasons are starting earlier and
ending later officials say climate
change is to blame and a gallica al
Jazeera